we all know who was the fastest man on
earth
there was a sign bolt he never drink
anything else all you when I started to
study medicine I saw that basically
everything is based on just drugs so
unfortunately we are not treating people
we are just treating symptoms yeah why
are so many people they're scared to
drink raw milk because of corporate
wealth forming their minds and views of
the people people is a usually ignorant
go on a television and see what
corporations which pasteurizing milk
telling them of course right guys we're
here at the goat farm and we're gonna
bring you some of the tremendous
benefits of drinking the milk how it was
ordained for us to drink the real raw
milk we'll talk about the benefits of
not only cow's milk but also the extra
benefits of goat's milk raw we call that
real milk not pasteurized not going
through the human process where you
destroy all the beneficial the majority
of the beneficial nutrients the
digestive enzymes in it that are in
there and people are actually getting
sick from not drinking the real milk but
drinking the fake milk the pasteurized
milk homogenized milk so we'll be
talking about that here on the Dean show
don't go anywhere
so much milk I can't even make the
cheese I make this just to try for
myself here in others because everybody
wanna milk last year I couldn't even
make maybe I make 3 times she is
secretly because everyone in milk you
just move disappeared I don't have a
milk and somebody like my friends and
Carla said do you Mike cheese we would
like to gossip al I don't have milk if
you don't have a milk probably you can
make cheese all you see this is a cheese
which was sitting in it you can try
which was sitting in it in a salt and in
a way that's mean this and salt I'm a
mom sick when I provide what kind of
salt sea salt is the best you know that
salt with the plenty of Jordan side
plenty you're Yoda iodine
well over six over 65 degrees Celsius
milk is pasteurized
that's very losing around 40% of all
important good things in a milk what you
should have in your body that's why raw
milk have all that but pasteurized milk
lose 40 percent of all that and that
milk which is a pasteurized can stay
long
but you see raw milk even if styie nope
even if come sour it snowed under
because you get the other product for
example you can put in a raw milk little
bit of yogurt two spoons on yogurt and
leave on a Sun here just preserve from
animals live on a Sun and after 24-48
hours
mix that together you have beautiful
yogurt you can drink it it's a top
quality that's mean it can't be done
just for you when is the milk healthy it
can't be done Jay even if you if staion
a Sun because you have different product
because a milk working all the time
works inside the milk a miking next
product but let's go back to the cheese
why are so many people they're scared to
drink raw milk because of a corporate
wealth forming their minds and views of
the people people is a usually ignorant
go on a television and see what
corporations which pasteurizing milk
telling them of course that milk in a
shop is a pasteurized they're selling
them and that's what they know they
never you see it only 5% of the people
on earth wanted to put nose behind a
fence to see what's going on why
somebody giving me all the option of
this I wanna have a look other things
because you see sadly Western countries
like Germany a
Australia New Zealand UK they even
prohibit to sell to the public raw milk
why because big corporations who own so
many thousands of calves sheep and
guides their pasteurizing milk to sell
to the public and they're making good
money and of course they'll sigh while
raw milk is no good there's the only
reason and people doesn't know people
what they watch on a television they see
the politician they see they corporate
magnets who is a multi million as
because of the emergency and that's what
they they what they following like a
sheep you know put the vanship over the
bridge the rest of them they go if you
ask them why are you going well I'm
going because one of them go first I
want to tell you how I make the cheese
you get that because this is wow this is
now raw goat cheese raw organic cheese
if you you see
we call that when you milk from the
goats
it would be ideal if you can pick up
stratify and bring the inside and keep
that temperature and put a staff call we
call that Maya here but that actually is
a special stuff which is a mite from the
stomach inside of the sheep in a body
and that come sour and that mixture we
call that Maya which is the organic de
miking bloke who have that formula only
in travnik near the washes he making
that sort of stuff and you put one spoon
in a five liters of the milk mix gently
up and down like this and gently around
No
to give it a fast meal fast mixing and
when you do that let us die for 2 hours
after 2 hours get a knife cut in a
squares like maybe 2 square centimeters
or 1 or whatever then just move them
together to separate the squares and
leave a more to our soul for doesn't
matter I sit it's not when that happened
when totally cool they all and you see
you got greenish this way on a top that
means cheese is at down then you stride
and put in it in shapes can you got this
goat cheese burger cheese which look you
can now this cheese you can put him
couple hours to dry then put them in a
special buckets with a salt and keep
them for wind after 9:00 dice but a fine
anodized they would become cheese which
I can show you I have a little bit of
example of that we can taste it I do
that so now we're drinking some soot
Rocca salute gun suit car in English way
raw raw way good help is me laugh
delicious it's not the way pretend it's
just the way right the way so this is
where they make that's the synthetic
version right yeah this is the real way
this is because somebody teaching this
is a why how you can get motive real way
I come to LA I'm what we're looking for
some real wrong go echo castle many knee
pad misses here in Bosnia so what when
did you milk the this so this is from
this morning
yes milking goats milk what are some of
the the benefits of goat milk that you
can share what raw goat's milk look Noah
goat's milk according to science from UK
United States of America is the 85%
equal to the mother's milk what we drink
when we born and how many percent eighty
five percent yes and Plus this milk is a
from organic food because my gut it
everything what is organic on this land
never been any chemicals and that is a
plus in my opinion goat's milk is that
the best milk on earth what you can have
that basically what can I say about
judgment we we also have a future
medical doctor here who's been studying
nutrition dingo also share with us some
of the insights that you've learned
about the benefits of
goat's milk it's not equal so la goat's
milk is a very good option if you're
searching for milk to drink because in
goat's milk you don't have a to cuisine
which is basically the allergic
substances that we have in cow's milk so
as the previous mister said so if it's
most like Mother's Milk so 85% is alike
and basically when you this is milk if
mother doesn't have milk to nourish the
child
so this milk of choice for you can you
tell us some of the we talked about the
goat's milk but what other foods do you
have here and how do you feel now you're
health-wise eating the real foods and
have you totally gone away from eating
much of the the fake foods and how is
eating this kind of food this is truly
organic food benefited your health well
I'm 61 years old and I can run now like
most of City blogs 2530 even more
benefit of the goat's milk is enormous
and plus plus one more thing I will show
you after we can try we can bring here
and try a product from goat's milk you
know when you have a cheese and after
that we have Howie I forgot English how
you're safe assorted Qinglin nananana
I'd say it's but back to the to the
future our nutritionist medical doctor
who's really
he's understood that in medical school
doctors don't learn about nutrition so
you went on your own to study nutrition
you were so amazed with it that you're
continuing going to medical school but
at the same time a parallel is happening
you're studying the benefits and getting
more educated on nutrition is that right
yeah so basically we haven't spent any
hour on learning about nutrition since
fourth year so basically now I'm
finishing the fourth year and I was
interested in a nutrition and
alternative medicine since I performed
hijama first it was before even I
started medical school so basically when
I started when I started to study
medicine I saw that basically everything
is based on just drugs so unfortunately
we are not treating people we are just
treating symptoms so we will we should
try to find out what is the cause of
diseases because for example if you look
about that is serious through the cancer
so you will see that how the doctor
stone are treating the people which have
cancer and they basically cure them with
allows help of course in three to four
months maybe a year depends on the
situation of the patient what key piece
of advice would you get would you give
for people out there who are trying to
better their health they're trying to
take care of this vehicle that the
crater is provided for us to get us
through life and now there they go to
the doctor they're confused they sit
there they get seen they wait an hour
they get seen for five minutes and just
like you said they get another drug but
they want to take their health to
another level what piece of simple
advice or a couple pieces of advice
would you give them well first of all I
would recommend them to eat as much raw
food as they can so avoid sugar Saward
refined especially refined sugars avoid
processed food fast foods so basically
you should eat and drink like for
example goat's milk that we mentioned
here it's ooh bran burrow bone broth
especially because it basically
regenerates all sorts in the
so so hon Allah you have a lot of
benefits inshallah can cure every
disease if we focus on our health
alrighty this is the goat cheese raw
goat cheese you just made this this
morning we got we also we also got some
raw goat cheese here so what would you
say are the benefits of now we talked
about the drinking the raw goat's milk
and also the benefits there's benefits
tremendously of raw and cow's milk also
right yeah hum doula we have as well
because when you drink as well cow's
milk but unprocessed uncooked so
basically a row when you only drink it
we have 10 times more electrolytes or
vitamins inside it then cooked so even
even when we mentioned cheese even it's
goats or cows it has a Norma's benefits
in our health but I would perform a
rather goat's milk instead of cow's milk
because of the previously mentioned
benefits so you mentioned some very
important not the conventional milk
because according to the Food and Drug
Administration they have as the number
one allergenic food is milk that's not
the real make that the creator gave us
to drink that's the processed milk
that's gone through the pasteurization
process the modernization process you
were talking about the real straight
from the source
yeah but I mean I understand that the
process why are they doing this because
when you have for example hundred or two
hundred cows and there is a lot of risk
of brucellosis or or other type of
contamination so basically because of
this they are doing those things but
unfortunately it is caused are harm to
our body so we should if we can we
should find the best or or nearest farm
and the guy the guy that we know for
example he he has he has foods which is
organic that gives to his animals so
basically we should take milk or
products from him not from the farms
one more thing I want to ask you what
about when you go to some of the
mustards you go you know to the
housewarming parties and you got first
thing on the table is the coca-cola you
know that the processed foods you said
stay away from that how important is it
to get it to someone's head to really
stay away from these foods now because
how detrimental is this to having good
health and avoiding bad health yep
though when we eat refined sugars
basically which I think you know koala
we have approximately five grams of
sugar refined sugar so basically we are
increasing your are increasing our it
increases basically the the causes of
diabetes for example of otros chlorosis
other diseases so basically refined
sugar as a now studies show that
basically they are number one especially
diary products which are derived from
conventional animals conventional food
so basically those products we should
avoid first we we should take care of
our health because Lord said us
levena Amano johannes konami entire bad
him out as a kanakam so basically this
word type means clear and it's not just
halal it's clear so we should eat raw
organic food beautiful advice beautiful
advice here eating at IE bad eating the
good food that the crater allows want
allows giving us and what were you
saying now what is this this is a NOS
product when you're making cheese from
the guides milk of course again we talk
about raw milk not pasteurized raw milk
and this news product is a cold why it's
a so nutritionist and so good we all
know who was the fastest man on earth
there was a sign bolt he never drink
anything else or use any medicals who to
get his body fit he had a special farm
on your Micah on Jamaica
and they're making so many hundreds of
liters God's product new product from
the cheese which is away and he drink
that because this is a basically
medication in one way it's clear up our
body from the mouse to the back all of I
and I would recommend everybody
everybody to drink special in the
morning when you wake up just cup like
this it's so good if you if you're gonna
well we we're not trying to explain in a
why of nutrients America but if you go
on a google and just ask Google to tell
you what is this you will see what
benefit you got from this but you
believe or not
90 percent people if you give them for
free they will walk wider they want a
drink because they ignorant because
ignorance is the biggest enemy for us
they have no idea like I said to you
when I offer the goat's milk hood to the
blokey you try said ah this is not God's
milk goats milk supposed to stink that's
that's his attitude what somebody else
told him he he never try before and
that's why we have to encourage people
to not just to to to drink to benefit of
that and it's real important both the
sisters to understand that there's a
difference between one food when you
have food a color and then tell you that
claim the real food the organic food you
know and there there came a time in
history when the food was just food it
wasn't organic it was just food but now
nowadays you know they've even
distinguished you have you know half a
million fake food items out there that
is destroying people's health you have
95 percent of chronic diseases our
food-related so we're trying to get
people at a white Bell level to remove
the coca-cola and the sodas from the
mustards and take it up a notch get rid
of all of the harmful elements that are
just invading the body toxic foods
poison
you wonder why your kids are sick you're
sick you're overweight you're obese
diabetes heart disease cancer through
the roof so you've got to get these
things right if you want to have good
health and honor the blessing of health
that allowed that the creator of the
heavens and earth has given you so this
is just one aspect of it we're talking
about it we're talk about the milk but
take it to another level and remember
this eat real food
avoid fake food and I'd love to see
people who have taken it seriously and
they're starting to educate their
communities in the masjid they're
starting to create awareness and i'm
telling you at the end this is what's
gonna pay off this is the preventative
measures that you're tying your camel as
the prophet saw some said you're doing
your part now and then from there
inshallah you put your trust in allah
subhanho wa taala Allah the Almighty